this is the mindset women want the
wedding more than they want the marriage
married to this man for long all she
wants is a husband now let's let's go
through her requirements I bet they're
very
deep
and like I I bet you know they're very
reasonable okay at 35 being a 35 year
old litigation attorney knowing knowing
that what you bring to a marriage at 35
years old is in all honesty nothing even
if you're a hottie which she seems like
an all right looking chick you know even
if you're a big hottie at 35 most men
get married because they want children I
would you ever get married if no kids
were involved no she the guys are
shaking their head so women know this
right the men look at you and they gotta
think could this woman raise some kids
right